Hey,
what's going on is bill bar and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just checking in on you.
How are you,
how was your week going?
What are you paying attention to when the news that's causing you to yell at
people you don't know online?
Huh?
What's going on?
Did you hear about this?
Somebody did this and then someone said that and the results may surprise you.
Okay.
All fucking day.
You know,
I walked through the God Damn airport and I'm just looking at all these fucking
people looking on their phones and you know what I see,
I see me.
That's what I see.
I'm like,
I'm doing that.
I'm just sitting there staring at my fucking phone,
looking at somebody's flipping a fucking water bottle,
somebody fucking dunking a basketball and everybody running away like the world
just ended somebody fucking playing the drums.
What am I doing?
You know,
I'd sit there and read a book,
you know,
so I look smart,
but no one would even notice.
They're all fucking staring at their phones.
So what is the point of reading in public?
If other people can't even see you're doing it because that's why you're doing
it,
right?
Nobody reads in public.
Okay,
you know what kind of a fuck.
Give a see some fucking asshole walking down the street with a book.
You know,
you're just across the street like we get it.
You're smart.
Okay.
MMM,
well maybe you do read in public.
Maybe that's what you're supposed to do.
You read in public so you get credit for it.
So everybody,
it's like that time back on the Seinfeld episode with Jason Alexander wanted to
get credit for tipping.
They didn't seem so,
he reached back in to do it.
Then they thought he was stealing.
I think it's like the literary version of that or maybe it isn't or maybe it is.
Um,
anyways,
I have something to promote here.
Um,
all things comedy network.
I need you guys to get behind this.
You know,
if you feel like in a no pressure here.
All right.
Ted.
Alexandra has a new special out that you can,
you can actually stream it right now.
Um,
at a t c specials.com.
It's called a senior class of earth.
And Ted is just one of those guys,
man,
I sweat it.
He's just one of those comics that every comic loves and uh,
but you know,
you know,
this business is for awhile.
They like this person,
then they want this person.
And he just was never that person,
which I can relate to.
This industry was never looking for a bald,
redheaded mail,
you know?
Okay.
So I,
I had to carve out my own path.
You like how making his special about me and my struggles.
You know why that is?
Because I'm on social media all the time and it's fucking frying my brain.
Um,
do you guys could go on and check out his special,
it would be a be great.
You'd see a great,
there's
actually this fucking killer clip of one of his jokes where he compares the fact
that he's in his late forties and his girlfriend's in her early thirties and was
saying that,
um,
he was comparing his sex drive versus hers,
which is in the prime to when Shaq played on the Celtics where it was still
shack.
But it didn't look like Shaq anymore.
Took them like half the game to warm up all of that stuff.
It's such a fucking killer joke.
And uh,
when you watch it,
what I love about Ted is there's no wasted words.
And even like,
even like the physicality of his jokes propels you towards the punchline.
He's a,
he's an absolute master.
So,
uh,
please check that out.
And with that and with that,
that anybody watched the Monday night football game
but it don't put it on the Kansas City chiefs against the fucking Denver Broncos
and um,
Jesus Christ.
I thought that announcer was going to fucking faint.
I have never heard an announcer.
So God damn excited about a regular season game,
but that my home's,
he's like,
shove,
type my homes captain,
come back,
fuck gained something else.
My home did anything that he did like when he was rolling.
I'm not saying the guys and good,
he's not going to be a fucking star.
One of the guys said,
you know,
he came into the game as a legend.
He's been playing for a month.
Right?
Everybody flipping the fuck out.
I know what it's a Goddamn business,
right?
You know,
Brady's fucking older than dirt.
This other fucking guy is like,
you know,
uh,
drew Brees.
He's like a year or two younger than Brady Manning.
Fucking read Tom so old.
I can't even get through these fucking names without yelling.
A Peyton manning fucking retired.
They need new people.
All right?
How many yards of these new people going to throw for when you can't even like
start the hug them and then stop and do the,
you know,
you know the me too thing.
Now we go to hug a friend of yours and then you start to think,
oh little,
you get all fucking nervous.
You know,
that's the way defensive lineman grab quarterbacks now and they still get a
fleck.
So anyways,
the guy fucking rolls out.
He's a right handed quarterback.
He rolls out to his left,
this guys breathing down his neck.
He dives at his ankles and right before,
uh,
my home's goes down,
he switched the ball to his left hand and threw it like four yards in.
This guy caught it,
which I,
I've saw Brett Farve do that.
I've seen Eli.
I've seen people do that before on this guys that gone.
I hope you realize what you just saw it here.
I think the NFL game cause like,
listen man,
you got to hype this fucking kid up.
Okay.
You're going to have to hype this fucking kid up.
And as always,
you know,
I'm,
I'm the fucking Grinch.
A sports don't ever listen to me.
I'm always telling everybody to fucking relax and not be excited.
I'm taken all the fun out of it.
But Kansas City,
as of right now,
he has the worst defense in all of football and everybody's freaking the fuck
out.
I mean they should be freaking out cause my homes is looking like the real deal,
but it's just like you're not,
if you don't,
if you don't fix that problem,
you're not going to do shit in January.
Yeah.
So I dunno what all this screaming and yelling at him is about.
Okay.
I hope you guys realize what pot,
what I just said here on this podcast.
Okay.
People going to,
that was like one of the greatest Monday night football games of all.
It's like was it seems like what happens every time I sit down to watch a game,
somebody is up by 10 and then goes into a fucking shit.
I Dunno what,
and then they lose the game when I was a kid.
Like that didn't happen.
Like it happens all the fucking time.
One of the greatest modern I Bob codes of all time.
Hey Ron made me have three regular season games I saw the day before.
You know,
if that was,
what about the fucking Bengals Falcons?
Like that wasn't,
I guess cause it didn't happen on Monday.
I Dunno.
Why am I such a jerk?
I have no idea.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
well you know,
who knows.
Um,
I'm going to be taking a,
ah,
it's Wednesday right now and I am taking a red eye flight out to Springfield,
Massachusetts to do shows in Springfield in uh,
Boston.
And then down in,
in uh,
Connecticut and Paul Verse.
He's going to be on me with all on all the shows.
And then I'm also working with,
uh,
some Boston guys that I started out with.
I'm working with Frank San Annarelli and Springfield.
Tony Vee at Boston Garden and then Dan Smith Down in Connecticut.
So it's gonna be,
uh,
it's going to be a lot of fun and I want to thank everybody that's bought the
tickets and or freckles is going to try to go out there and not put on 40 pounds
because of,
um,
you know,
I'm going to go back there.
It's going to be all the old haunts,
you know,
you go back east,
they got the fucking insane Chinese food,
uh,
the pizza,
all of that stuff.
So I got to like ice cream joints that I used to all this shit that I'm,
this is what it,
what happens whenever I go back to Boston is like,
I,
because I left in [inaudible] 95
I go back to,
uh,
you know,
I start acting like I'm 22 years old way I'm eating,
which somehow back in the day,
you know,
you'd go out and drink a 12 pack and then hit Mcdonald's at the end of the night
and go home and the next morning just wake up and go unload trucks.
You stomach was flat,
you know,
you just shook it off back then.
You know,
it's like doing your first burnout in a brand new car,
like the car getting,
you know,
probably wished you didn't do it.
Probably not happy it did it,
but it can shake it off.
It's still looks new,
you know,
now I tried to do that shit.
There's like fucking parts left on the road.
Um,
anyways,
so it's so Ba October and I wasn't going to do it,
but now I'm going to do it.
Oh well fuck it,
do it.
You know,
I'm a binge drinker.
I got to stop with the Shit,
you know,
I'll do it.
So now I'm on the wagon alum date,
but the potato potato to,
you know what's funny is people,
there's like two different ways of saying you're on the wagon.
There's like,
um,
you know,
like uh,
you're on the party wagon or your,
your,
the way I said,
if I'm on the wagon,
that always meant like you're not on,
you're not party.
He fell off the wagon,
meant you started partying again.
But then other people call the wagon,
the party wagon.
So I dunno,
it's just one of those things,
you know,
it's kind of like that word cock with white people.
It meant Dick and with,
with black older black people,
I should say it meant pussy,
you know,
just a complete inverse.
I mean,
it's sort of an extreme example,
but
I remember saying that in the writer's room
and an f is for family and they were like,
that's not true,
is it?
And then they end up having this fucking snoop Dogg song from the early nineties
where your first to a woman's pussy as his cock.
So fucking weird.
Oh,
people,
people have different ways of saying thanks,
don't they?
That was sort of my Mr. Rogers moment of the podcast.
I know there's a bunch of people right now fucking Google in that.
Go ahead and Google it.
Go ahead and go.
You know what?
I'll fucking Google it.
I'll,
I'll read.
I'll read it to you right now.
This could be,
so maybe this could be something interesting.
Um,
by the way,
have you guys been following anybody?
Like I told you,
have you follow it?
Been following anybody for sarcastically on Twitter,
watching them make all of these news events about themselves,
you know,
telling you how difficult it is to be beautiful,
you know?
All right,
let me see here.
Cock.
Oh Jesus Christ would fucking,
this is going to be on my search engine.
Okay.
Alright.
Cock a doodle.
Cockroach.
Cox Spirer cockroaches.
Cockapoo alright.
Cock meaning
pussy.
Thank you.
I'm 50 years old.
I just searched that.
All right,
let's see what happens.
We'll the FBI show up at my door and we're waiting and we're waiting because
bill has the worst Internet service and there we go.
Uh,
cock means vagina.
Let us explain.
La Weekly wrote an article about this.
Uh
Oh,
let me see here.
Okay.
Oh,
this is the one coc meeting vagina.
Let us explained now I don't want us fucking subscribe to the La Weekly.
K Rodney Carmichael's early high school years were awkward.
Like many young men,
he wasn't sure how to talk to girls.
This was of a problem for a stepbrother who gives a shit.
Okay,
hold on.
All right.
He never met a girl in person,
but recalls that his step are the promise.
She was cute.
Even better.
She'd seen Carmichael from afar and thought the same thing about him.
So their phone calls slowly.
Miranda meandered from getting to know you phase too.
Clumsy Highschool attempts at flirtation.
Then she asked a question that stopped him in his tracks.
Do you eat cock?
Wait,
that's not a fucking clumsy flirtation.
That's fucking direct.
It's like a fucking military.
Do you eat cock for private?
Alright.
Carmichael was confused.
Okay.
Uh,
to the young black man.
Everything to that point had suggested a typical teenage heterosexual courtship.
But the question threw him for a loop.
Okay.
He's like,
I didn't know if she was talking about minor Hersey.
He remembers.
It was kind of nerve wracking.
His confusion was understandable.
He didn't use the word cock much himself,
but he had heard it by white folks in the media,
Hbo,
old playboy who was slang for penis when it was used by some of his famous rap
FAPE,
favorite rappers.
However it meant something else entirely.
Take Miami rap act two live crew.
That group obsessed equally with bass and female anatomy,
uh,
and most famously by most famous hit me.
So horny also had a song called HBC in which they chanted head,
booty and cock.
Uh,
what you like fellows head,
booty and cock.
Okay.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I don't remember that song.
And two live crew.
Jesus Christ.
What?
Okay.
Snoop dog.
When I bust my Nep,
I'm raising up off the cock.
Snoop Dogg wraps his iconic 1993 hit gin and juice.
Yeah.
MMM.
Okay.
All right.
So we've got enough exam x examples.
So no surprise that fledging quote,
courtship quickly wound down,
nobody's cock was ever eaten,
but comic definitely wasn't alone in this confusion.
There were surely many casualties.
And in an era when hip hop,
sudden popularity forced this old bit of slang into a head on collision with the
broader culture for one group of people cock referred to male Genitalia for the
other referred to female day or we go,
Huh.
And that's one to grow on.
See everybody,
you know,
every once in a while you'll learn something here
on the fucking Thursday afternoon podcast.
What do you think about that?
Huh?
All right.
So you got to be asking yourself,
the New England patriots,
a play in the fucking Indianapolis Colts or rivalry,
arguably the biggest rivalry in the NFL during the Wella and Peyton manning was
there.
Maybe,
you know,
I always thought the Steelers ravens was a good one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Who the fuck knows anyways,
it was,
it was a big rival,
but now,
you know,
it's a different time.
Andrew Luck,
you know,
took a year off getting healthy.
Now he's
back.
Who knows what happens.
I love what the Patriots did on Sunday.
Oh,
by the way,
I did I fucking call the fucking Broncos a what they covered.
They still blow the fucking game,
but I was so hoping to actually going to win the game.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
the Patriots did so well against the dolphins.
That's the team that I want to show up on Thursday.
But the Thursday games a weird cause.
Everybody's fucking tired.
They usually sloppy as shit.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I keep,
I keep hearing Edelman is going to be back and then other people say isn't going
to be back.
I don't know.
But if he's back,
you know,
we got that dude,
you know who likes to party like me,
I'm in from Cleveland.
It help our defense can get a little pressure on the quarterback.
Something.
I don't know if we got a shot,
we got a shot to go on a little run here.
We'll see.
We shall see what happens.
MMM.
So I went to the gym today,
right.
And uh,
I forgot my headphones
and um,
you know,
see that plane,
you don't gym music and Shit,
right?
Yeah.
And Dude,
I got to say at my fucking gym,
it is so funny.
It's such like a,
like I've,
I've,
I haven't been in a gym in like 11 or 12 years.
I always worked out in my garage,
but now cause I need to do the lat pull downs to finally build strength up in my
shoulder so I can finally do a pull up again.
So I don't lose like 200 bucks when I turned 70,
because I can't do 10 pull ups.
That's the bet.
Um,
with Versie that I have.
And um,
so I joined this gym and I haven't been in the gym so long.
Like there is just so many different fucking workouts,
Eh,
cause you know,
back in the day they used to be,
I'd go to a gym and I'd be like,
that guy doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
You know?
And that person really knows what they're doing.
I should ask them for some tips on how to work out.
But now I haven't been in there so long and there's just so many.
I mean when it,
last time I was a member of the gym,
like I don't think there was even kettle balls,
forget about all of this other shit where people stand on things like trying to,
uh,
you know,
it's like they got half a beach ball that they're standing on it while they're
doing curls and they're also working their core.
I mean,
I dunno.
So then I see people doing other shit and it's just like,
okay,
so is that a legit exercise or is that person just fucking weird?
I saw a guy on,
on,
you know,
instead of doing dips,
he lifted himself up,
he locked his arms out
and then he was just like scissor kicking side to side.
Like he was running in the air.
Yeah.
And I was like,
is that for your ankles?
Like what is,
what does that,
I imagine that's something for your core.
He wasn't bringing his legs up though.
It was like he was just sort of running in the air.
Like you know those douchebags who do pull ups and they act like they're walking
upstairs.
You know,
like one person did it,
it was cool and then 40,000 people did it and that just immediately became
Douchey,
like roller blading.
Um,
oh,
what did I hear this guy say today at the gym?
It was a self,
I was going to fucking write it down and I forgot
he was just talking about a show that he liked and I was just going,
there's no way that wasF is for family.
He said,
I just thought that they were really delicate with the,
some sort of something sort of subject.
Okay.
So it was a guy talking.
I liked that show because they're really,
uh,
they cherish something,
blah,
blah blah.
I don't know if he was hitting on the woman he was talking to or whatever,
trying to act like we was fucking sensitive,
you know.
But I know they weren't talking aboutF is for family and speaking of F is for
family.
Uh,
Netflix put out their first bit of social media about a season three,
which I'm very excited about it.
Um,
it,
uh,
dropped I think 11:00 AM or something.
I guess it's the next day.
So you guys probably already saw it if you haven't seen it.
Fence.
Vine is doing a voice to season and um,
it's probably the most fun I've had in the,
uh,
in the recording booth with somebody.
He,
that guy is like,
he's completely in his own land.
He is a fucking monster.
How funny that guy is.
And um,
I did my best to try to keep up with them,
which I don't think I did,
but I'm once again just another,
you know,
huge person to add to the cast and obviously added the funny,
that's why I think this is our best season.
And um,
and it's obviously his production
company,
wild west for the whole fucking reason that the show exists.
Begin with.
So a,
I want to thank him and I want to thank all you guys.
Uh,
if you're even thinking of watching it,
hopefully you will watch it and then we will get to do it all over again.
And hopefully this time next year I'll be talking about a season four,
but let's not get ahead of ourselves.
The Yankees,
I don't know what happened.
Okay.
It's,
it's the fucking day before.
Oh No,
it's today it's happening today.
Maybe there are they playing right now?
They're playing the Oakland A's and I,
I have no feeling about this game.
I have no idea who's gonna win this fucking one.
But,
uh,
like the fucking check in here.
What have we got?
Yanked
d
the Yankees.
Are they going to play tonight?
What time it's on TV?
Yes.
All right,
I'll have to check this out.
No,
you know what?
I'll actually be going to the fucking airport so I'm going to miss it.
Maybe I'll watch it on the plane.
Should be singing Yankee fans on there,
right.
Flying to whatever the fuck I'm flying to.
Um,
so anyways,
I got some ad reads to read here,
but I don't have them with me,
so I'm just going to say I have them and then I'm gonna I guess we'll drop it in
through the magic of fucking,
I don't know what magic of editing.
Yeah.
So I'm definitely going to do,
uh,
the sober October thing.
I gotta do it,
man.
I,
I don't know what my deal is.
What is it?
When if you drink,
you just fucking take it to the end,
but you can also just stop.
Where did,
where does that exist on,
like addiction,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I can literally just stopped drinking and I let her have alcohol sitting.
I just walk by it every day.
I don't even fucking see it.
But then when I get back on,
then I just fucking,
I dunno,
just slamming them
then I'm thinking I used to be my last one.
This will be my last one.
And I'm just like,
I'm still,
I'm still not,
I,
maybe it's my tolerance.
It's like I don't feel anything.
And then the next day I wake up,
I'm like,
oh my God,
I feel like Shit.
Whoa.
I was way drunk than I thought.
Um,
I'm always amazed at those people that can just sip,
you know?
Maybe it's just how I'm wired.
Like a bump playing drums.
I'm going to fucking play drums.
If I'm going to go do a tour,
it's going to be really fucking long or some shit.
And if I'm going to drink,
I'm gonna drink.
So
I dunno.
I'm just too fucking old for it.
And uh,
I dunno,
but this is what always happens.
Now I'll,
I'll stop for awhile,
month,
two months,
a fucking year or whatever,
and then I just,
I just get bored.
MMM.
There's gotta be like a,
okay.
It's gotta be a hobby that I can come up with.
Dude.
These fucking people like chasing you around the fucking Internet.
Look at this art deco bar cabinet.
I looked up maybe getting an art deco bought.
Hilarious is I'm sitting there talking about I'm,
I could fucking drink anymore.
I looked that up
like fucking six months ago and they just keep,
okay.
Now I just clicked on it just to talk to you guys about,
and this will just never leave.
I don't give a shit what I,
I could be looking up something about platypuses and in the side of my fucking
thing,
it's going to say art deco bars.
Look at the sinks.
Oh my God.
They are beautiful.
It's expensive as shit though.
Jesus.
Fuck you.
I he pain all of that.
My God.
Yeah.
Oh,
but they are abused.
That's David Shit.
I think also because I grew up watching bugs bunny that I like art deco shit.
Cause if you watch bugs bunny,
there's a lot,
all the buildings and stuff,
you know,
which people you know really hate it.
To be honest with you.
When they first came out they didn't like art deco.
They never liked the new shit.
You know,
like me,
I never liked the new shit.
What did I just bitching about?
Bitching about fucking Patrick.
My homes wasn't even bitching about him.
I think he's fucking great,
but she,
that,
that announcement,
my God,
I,
those was a couple of times like I think this guy's going to faint.
I live,
you think he's going to fucking pass out if this guy,
if he like hands off the ball and then they're given case keen,
I'm no fucking respect whatsoever.
The guy only went to the fucking NFC championship last year,
right.
Only beat the saints in the last play of the fucking game.
Right.
Granted that was the saints fucking up of,
speaking of which set guy plays on the cults now I believe.
Um,
but uh,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I guess when that Shit first came out,
people just did not like it on any level.
Ah,
look at that one.
Jeez,
look at this other thing.
You can't fucking see unique art deco whiskey bar cabinet.
Now how in the fuck am I supposed to not drink?
Okay.
When there's bars like this that I can buy.
Okay,
well what makes us a whiskey bar bill?
Well,
you know what?
You put whiskey.
Oh,
there you go.
Okay.
It has little fucking holes in it.
What are you reached down and you get the bottle like that comes up like Michael
Jackson used to come up onto the stage.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't like shopping online.
I'll tell you what I need,
man.
I need a fucking fly.
Swatter and mosquitoes are just off the hook right now.
Did I say off the hook that I say they are raising the roof?
Did I used to watch fucking Arsenio Hall talk show back in the [inaudible] they,
I think I did.
Um,
yeah.
These things are like,
they are not taking any prisoners.
This is a,
this is special forces.
Mosquitoes.
I got like welts on me and Shit and they are fastest shit.
Oh my,
my hand eye coordination isn't what it used to be.
Um,
but you really mixed the fly swatter is,
is the holes in it.
You know what I mean?
So as it's moving through the air,
it's like,
it's like the stealth bomber.
Nobody can here,
you don't even know it's got a fucking jet engine.
It's not,
they can't hear it.
It's,
it's that data.
They can't pick it up on radar.
Is that what it is?
I don't know.
I bet they can.
Now.
You know,
we don't admit it because he's spent so much money because it's like,
oh,
we can't find that thing.
And then they take pictures of it.
Oh,
that's what it is.
Okay.
It looks like a,
uh,
it looks like if someone was going to carve a cock,
meaning a dick in a lake and they didn't quite finish that in quite rounded off.
Um,
but anyways,
the flyswatter cause it has all those holes.
It's like a Prius when it first starts off.
You know,
you can't hear.
Like,
if someone's trying to run you down with a Prius,
when they first left the curb,
you wouldn't hear it.
By the time you really hear that engine fucking turned on,
it would be too late.
That's what it is.
The flyswatter is the Prius of,
um,
of fly killers,
I think.
Right.
Cause what else you got?
You got that tape and you hang down.
Um,
I always thought that that was just brutal.
That fucking,
that's like that mouse thing because you just go into the glue trap and they
like fucking ripping themselves apart,
trying to get out of it.
Um,
there's no need for that.
Right?
Just get a cat.
Those creepy ass fucking things.
Yeah.
If you get a feeling like somebody is stealing from you,
you know,
you've got just tells you you don't trust this person.
I've always felt that way about cats.
I don't fucking trust those things as far as I could throw in and I would throw
in because it's going to land on its paws anyways.
Right?
Um,
anyways,
I have a plane to catch everybody.
This is gotta gotta be the biggest bunch of nonsense I've ever said in my
fucking life.
Um,
I'm going to be at the Boston Garden on Friday night and I'm getting together
with some friends I used to play with back in the day to gym during the day in
the arena.
This time,
unlike the forum,
I will not be going for fucking,
you know,
three and a half hours.
Uh,
I,
oh,
I'm going to do,
it's like 90 minutes or something.
Get in there,
have a good time and then just fucking,
you know,
leave them wanting more.
So,
um,
I want to thank everybody.
Boston.
I sold more tickets than I've ever sold in my life.
I can't believe it.
I'm actually in denial about it so I can fucking mentally get through it.
And um,
it's really going to be crazy because I actually started my standup career at
Nick's comedy.
Stop on Warren Street,
March 2nd,
1992 and 26 and a half fucking years later,
you know,
to be right down the streets.
Pretty cool man.
Pretty fucking cool.
Um,
but it ain't going to be cool for freckles.
Has a bad show.
So,
uh,
I will be making sure.
Well that's good now because now it's sober October now I said it to you guys,
you know,
and I love that Rogan does that shit cause it makes me want to fucking do it.
Um,
so if you guys can come up with a good rhyme for me,
maybe I'll go for November.
You know,
remember sober.
Remember November
now.
It doesn't have a good ring to it.
What would have,
I'll let you guys come up with it.
Send me,
send me your pitches and I'll see if it works.
And if it doesn't,
I'll blame my binge drinking on you guys.
All right,
that is it.
Have a great weekend.
Your concent.
Once again,
thank you to everybody who's coming out to Springfield,
um,
Boston and Connecticut.
And please watch ted.
Alexandra is special and all things,
uh,
ATC special.
Sorry,
senior class of earth streaming now.
All things comedy.
All right.
All right,
here we go.
Here's the first sweet,
alright,
saucy behave everyone at some point as wished they could just have beer,
wine,
or liquor delivered.
Christ.
I'm trying to get sober while someone finally decided to do something about it.
Um,
introducing Southie.
The alcohol delivery APP saucy delivers your favorite wine,
beer,
and liquor,
right to your door on demand.
Now,
if you're in Los Angeles,
the bay area,
Chicago,
San Diego,
or Sacramento,
you're thoughts.
The order will arrive at your door in under 30 minutes,
ready to drink.
If you break out into the fucking dts in that 30 minutes,
maybe you got a problem for the rest of us saw.
See,
we'll deliver beer,
wine,
and liquor to your door in days or less.
Nationwide.
There were no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you've got the saucy APP,
you've got to fully stocked bow on your phone,
no delivery minimums.
Now what our minimum spoke,
you've got a keg party,
they'll handle it,
and for a limited time you can get $15 off when you download your thought,
the APP and enter your Promo Code Bur bur that's the thought.
The APP spelled s a,
u c e,
y and enter Promo Code Bird,
sorry,
Promo code birth for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today and use Promo Code burb a right.
My bookie,
I you fucking doing.
Ah,
I'm sure watching football is fun,
but it's more entertaining when you have your fucking weeks paycheck on and off
when you have some action on the games.
Guys have,
you've heard me talk about this for weeks and some of you are still on the
sidelines,
whether you're an expert or a rookie,
you should be betting at my bookie.
If you're the kind of guy,
they're fucking legs to bed.
A little win a lot like playing the numbers on roulette.
You can create a big parlay,
picked three teams to win and if you hit all three,
you'll turn a hundred dollars into 600 if not,
you're going to lose 100 bucks.
It's not just football.
You can bet all major sports.
Take MMA this weekend.
Conor Mcgregor,
by the way,
inside story I heard all that bullshit about him party and all that fucking room
is the inside.
I heard that,
uh,
that isn't true.
He was in great shape.
Whether it went so would not,
I dunno,
steps into the octagon on say for his first UFC fight in two years.
You can bet on things like whether he'll win straight up or weather cub Kabib
could be,
we'll deliver a first round knockout.
I recommend these guys because I really trust them.
This is the one bet I know you'll be happy with all season.
My book,
he has been in business for years.
They've got great online reviews and their mobile site is easy to use.
If you're on the sidelines.
Now is the time to get in the game.
My bookie will still match your first deposit dollar for dollar,
but you got to join now because they're pulling that offer.
Log onto my bookie right now and double your money.
Use Promo Code Bur bur and you'll get your first deposit match.
100% that's Promo Code [inaudible] you play,
you win,
you get paid.
All right.
Who's next?
Oh,
by the way,
since I fucking recorded this podcast,
congratulations to the New York Yankees.
Huh?
We're going to go head to head again above fucking time.
We'll see what happens.
It's a short series.
Anything can happen.
All right.
Helix,
Helix.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
Oh,
you're so special.
So why would you buy a generic mattress built for everyone else?
Um,
Helix,
helix sleep matches your body to the perfect mattress,
so get the best sleep of your life.
They Dillup Deliv.
They've delayed,
developed Jesus.
Nine different mattresses tailored to specific body types and sleep preferences.
Just go to helix.
sleep.com/burr take their two sleep quiz and they'll match you to a mattress
that's perfect for you.
Contouring to your body to provide unprecedented comfort and better sleep.
30% of headaches.
Sleep customers report better sleep after switching to their customized mattress
from Helix sleep right now,
they're offering up to $125 off all mattress orders,
whether you're a side sleeper,
a hot sleeper,
a power bottom,
or like a plush or firm bed.
Hey,
got the mattress that will fit a fit just right.
Get up to $125 off he looks.
sleep.com/ [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr $425 off your
mattress.
Order.
Hey,
he looks sleep.
How asleep.com/bar.
Oh look who's here to do these.
Mia,
Andy's the red sox and the Yankees.
Doo,
Doo.
Me undies,
me undies.
You to fucking hammered.
Gimme your keys.
You're going to shit your pants watching this shit.
No matter what happens,
ESPN will say,
this is it.
It's a couple of fucking $200 million teams.
What about the fucking a me undies?
The lounge pants are made from the same micro Modelo fabric is their undies.
They make an lounge pants.
Oh my God.
You mean for lounging around?
I want to get some of these.
Let me tell you,
you'll be in fall heaven when you cover your entire bottom half with fabric that
is three times softer than cotton.
You thought your balls felt,
felt soft way to you feel your knees.
Uh,
me always loves celebrating the fall season with fun Halloween Prince.
Check out their latest Jack Atlanta prince in undies,
socks and bralettes pronounced bralette.
Uh,
the best part when you join the membership,
you can get all this stuff.
Lounge pants,
teas and undies.
Um,
everything me undies makes for less than anyone else.
Special member pricing is just one of the many perks of joining the membership.
Uh,
talk about why me and these are the best underwear.
Feel free to improvise.
Well,
you know,
my balls used to be sad and you know,
feeling like they weren't respected as they were shaped when they were up
against cotton.
You know.
And then one day I came in with the micro modal or whatever the fuck they're
making this shit out of am I,
I have never gotten along with my ball bag better.
Um,
we were really still in the honeymoon phase of this underwear.
Guys,
I've said it time and time again.
I love these undies.
I said that they are the softest underwear I ever put on and they come with fun
prints that I can match with socks or my bralette
hey damn man,
tits hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed.
You're going to love these undies.
But if you're not into what Mandy's,
we'll go,
we'll do whatever they can to get you into the right pair.
If they can't keep them and they'll refund you.
So it's really is risk free to try the best underwear ever.
Uh,
Biondi says a great offer for my listeners for the first time,
I'm sorry for any first time when you purchase any media,
these you can get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on to get
your 15% off your first pair of free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
This is bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 4th,
2010 and I'm doing it really,
really late,
super late,
super,
super late.
Like that whore you bang the freshman year of fucking high school.
You know,
we'll stop stressing out about it.
That's what's making it not happen.
You're not fucking pregnant.
Yeah.
And with that girl,
everybody had that girl,
right?
The one girl who gets fucking pregnant,
like eighth grade,
ninth grade,
you know,
you go back for your 10 year high school reunion and she's standing there with a
22 year old.
You're like,
look at you.
Good for you.
Why you still got it?
Actually that's my son.
MMM,
that's right.
You standing there with their three kids and they all have like beards and
mustaches are a full rack of titties.
Um,
anyways,
I'm super late because,
um,
I hung around for an extra day in buffalo and uh,
consumed about 9,000 calories.
I went to a,
the buffalo bills,
New York jets game and then afterwards I went to the Buffalo Sabre Philadelphia
Game.
And uh,
I just had a fucking awesome time out there,
man.
I'm the first night actually worked in Albany,
New York.
I was working the egg and I want to thank everybody who showed up.
Man.
I had a great turnout for both shows.
It's my first little,
uh,
my first little dip into the theater market.
Stuck my little toe in there,
you know?
Okay.
MMM.
Did I gotta tell you,
man,
I had the scariest fucking flight I've had in like 10 years flying in from
Chicago to Albany,
right.
I live out here on the fucking west coast now.
So yeah,
for some goddamn reason,
Los Angeles is this international airport.
But,
well,
that's not true.
It's because it's the other side of the country.
Yeah.
I mean,
I can get a fucking direct flight
to like,
uh,
I dunno,
Bakersfield.
I'm trying to pick some fucking obscure city,
but whatever,
to get to Albany,
I got to fly into Chicago and then I that which,
which,
which was no problem.
And then I flew from Chicago to Albany and when we came in on final approach,
I don't know what happened.
The guys like,
we're coming in for final approach and we just was,
we were in this fucking soup.
We were in this job or whatever the pilots call it,
and we're just going up 500 feet down 600 backups,
seven and we're just in this shit.
And,
uh,
as I,
as I've stated before here on the podcast,
I don't mind turbulence when I'm way up in the fucking air,
I don't give a shit drop a thousand feet where 30,000 off the fucking ground.
I don't care.
Right.
But when you like coming in on final approach,
all of a sudden drop in five,
600 feet,
you know,
you start hitting TV antennas like back in the day,
like Fred Flintstone when he didn't want to get busted for whatever the fuck he
was doing.
Right?
And he started driving around the neighborhood last so in the antennas,
what the hell was he doing?
Was He cheating on Wilma?
Am I doing some,
some stand up comedy material from the 1980s?
Is that,
is that what I'm doing?
Who is it?
Do it.
Um,
so we're just in this shit and this guy says we're in final approach.
Okay.
And like 15 fucking minutes later,
I'm,
I'm just looking out the window doing what I always do.
Go and give me some lights.
Let me see some fucking lights of the city so I can figure out how high up we
are so I can figure out how much I need to be freaking out.
And we just kept flying through the shit and it was like really,
really bad to the point I was actually feeling a little bit queasy.
Right?
And this guy's not saying shit and I'm thinking,
fuck,
we're flying into Albany who flies into Albany,
you know,
is that the the fucking,
is that Tom Brady flying that plane or do we got the backup?
Why don't we know his fucking name?
Albany,
the studs,
they flying into JFK,
they fly into Laguardia,
they fly into Newark.
They don't fly into Albany.
Right.
So I'm sitting there freaking the fuck out going up.
God,
we got,
we got the fucking backup to the backup.
We get Trent Dilfer is backup pliant flying the Goddamn plane.
And uh,
so I did some,
I haven't done in a while.
I started praying to God,
Huh?
Oh Gee.
That's how bad it was.
I the fucking hedge my bets going,
hey,
you know,
I've been talking a lot of trash about you on the Monday morning podcast.
Wait a minute,
do I even need to explain it considering you know,
everything,
um,
now.
So I was like,
all right,
sorry for this.
Sorry for that.
Sorry for my ceds.
And I'm really starting to get nervous because we're still fucking,
you know,
people's stomachs to drop in and I'm really fucking pray.
And,
and then all of a sudden I heard this woman,
uh,
puke like 10 rows back,
right?
Everybody is like visibly nervous and no one has led out the bitchy scream yet.
And then I just heard this lady like 12 rows back.
Oh,
right.
So I start laughing my fucking ass off.
It's exactly what I need.
A little bit of humor so I can just completely pave over any sort of emotion
that I'm feeling.
And then we were back in the fucking chop again.
And then the pilot finally comes on and says,
yeah,
they have us in a holding pattern because you can see this a storm.
And what I didn't get was,
why didn't you fly up above it or fly east of the shit or get away from it?
We just stayed in it.
We were flying in circles in this fucking storm and we would,
we would get to the point where it was sort of tolerable and then go back into
it again.
And,
uh,
it was really getting bad.
I was trying to read a magazine and made me like Carsick,
which I guess is air sick when you're up there,
but it's the same shit.
And uh,
and then I heard this guy like two rows behind me,
you know,
he let out this really bitchy like,
Ooh,
as we were going over the thing and I actually made me fucking angry,
you know,
Christ say,
hold the fucking,
get yourself together,
fucking start making those noises,
making everybody scared you asshole.
So we did that.
That's what it was for fucking 40 minutes.
We were in this shit and uh,
people were puking.
People will make an woo woo woo.
Like literally like that.
And,
uh,
and I'm sitting there trying to fucking remember what prayers you're supposed to
say from back in the days when I was an altar boy.
Right?
You're fucking rang the bells.
And on the third day he said,
this is what I've done for you.
I can't remember how to say this is my body,
which will be given up for you.
That's why you ring it.
Dang it.
Dang.
With the fucking the bells there.
At least that's how we did it.
You know,
that's the only lame attempt at my church we made to try to fucking compete with
whatever was going on fucking in the inner city.
Right?
They probably had Aretha Franklin headline and or some shit.
You just had me looking like a young fucking oop Cunningham,
whatever the fuck it goddamn dude's name was.
I never watched that show.
The Andy Griffith show.
I always found it depressing watching those broadcast southern people that town
drunk.
It was never funny to me.
So anyways,
we finally fucking land and everything was good.
Go to Albany,
I do the Gig,
everything's fucking great.
Then I go out to buffalo drive and across the state in New York,
absolutely gorgeous day.
And the second I even get within the facility,
first of all,
every told me it was a fucking five hour drive,
six hour drive from Albany to buffalo.
What?
Uh,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I Dunno how people drive,
but a,
you can go a lot faster than that.
Three hours and 50 minutes you pussies.
So I go in there and the second I get into buffalo,
it's like fucking
pouring down rain.
I'm sorry.
I thought I hit the stop on here.
It just to me that it was the most miserable fucking weather.
And uh,
I ended up doing my show and I don't know what's going on.
I'm fucking tired and I lost interest in this story.
What do you think about that?
Yeah,
how do I regroup here?
You know what fuck me up was I thought I stopped my record of,
God dammit.
This is why I don't do my podcasts on the same day that I fly is because I'm so
fucking sleepy that I,
I can't,
I can't focus.
I keep trying to fucking keep the momentum going and I just can't do it.
I just can't fucking do it.
Let's,
let's just try to hit the highlights.
I get to Buffalo,
I do the Goddamn show.
I have a great time.
And the other comedian I'm working with,
me and Paul Versey,
we're like,
well,
you know this is buffalo.
They are known for their wings.
They're always talked and shit,
right?
Philly cheese steak.
You go to Philly,
you get a cheese steak,
right?
You go to fucking Atlantic City,
you get you,
you get fucking,
you get your dick suck in the alley.
Right behind the fucking blue and beige Trump casino.
You do you.
You do what?
The Ryan one in Rome.
You do what the Romans do.
So fuck it.
We're in Buffalo.
Let's go get some goddamn buffalo wings.
It's go get some wings.
So a,
there's two places to go.
You either go to Tufts,
so you go to anchor bar and Duff's was right down the street.
So we said,
fuck it.
Let's go there.
And I got to tell you,
you want to talk about living up to the hype.
Best fucking wings I ever had.
All right.
It had a crunchy outside.
You don't like what people don't know how to make the wings around the rest of
the country when the crunch on the outside is crunchy.
That means a,
as my dad would say,
Christ,
you're cooked a shit out of bed.
Um,
yeah.
Usually that means somebody over cooked it.
Oh,
is my dad eloquently puts it,
cook the shit out of it.
So way he's always here.
Christ,
you're cut the shit out of it.
Um,
face all twisted up.
Anyways,
that's back when you could curse in restaurants,
you know,
tell you it's so,
we lost so many rights after nine 11,
I swear to God.
Remember it used to be able to walk into Mcdonald's and you get your French
fries and they would call and you could just yell at the manager,
Hey,
hey fucking dude.
Yeah.
What the f?
Well,
they're fucking cold.
I'm sorry sir.
Let me get you some other ones.
Yeah,
you do that
right?
Isn't that what you were able to do or those my drinking years,
I can't remember.
That's how I,
that's how I did it.
So anyways,
once again,
I've lost my train of thought.
I don't know where I am.
Yeah.
So we go in there and they're literally,
they're fucking crunchy on the outside and they're dead juicy on the inside and
they got unbelievable sauce.
And we got the duff beer.
It was the shit.
Now,
evidently when Obama went there,
this is another place.
It's a place called anchor bar.
I guess when Obama went there,
he flipped a coin.
He went to Tufts.
So we went to the same place to president,
went to.
But then afterwards,
I'm half,
fuck it.
I've got to tell that part of the store out.
Jesus.
You know what this is.
This is like,
uh,
the first draft of a script,
except this is all I got budget for.
This is like,
does it mean to be like a fucking Edwood movie cut.
That was perfect.
Moving on.
So the next day I go to the,
the bills game.
All right.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm doing my little hundred dollar bet.
I'm picking three games against the spread.
Once again,
this week I went one and two.
I went one and two last week on two and four,
a pitiful two and four.
Even if I teased my teams last week,
I still would have lost with the fucking,
uh,
Falcons beat and the saints and overtime.
So this week,
who did I have,
first of all,
dumbest thing you get,
you can do as a gambler is I bet with my heart.
So I'm sitting there going to write the bills are getting five.
I know every football fan out there right now is going,
oh Geez.
That's cause you know the fucking final result.
All right.
I'm thinking all right,
the jets have been playing great.
They should go in and absolutely destroy this team.
It's fucking raining out.
It's a divisional Ravelry this is the exhibit and they got a couple of injuries
and the secondary,
this is the exact kind of a fucking game that goes the exact opposite way,
right?
And plus I hate the jet.
So I say fuck it.
I'm taking the pills and then I also took the Bengals against Cleveland.
I lost that one.
And there was one other one that I took.
I pick the fucking ravens.
I got to stick with the Ravens,
man.
The Ravens had been good to me and so of the lions,
but I think the cat's out of the bag that the lions can actually hang so then it
can be getting fucking 13 point spreads anymore.
But anyways,
um,
so I show up there,
right?
And I'm walking into the stadium.
It's fucking raining out.
Ah,
Jesus.
I fucked this part of the story up to,
you know what?
Fuck this podcast Greg.
She had cooked the shit out of it.
Um,
yeah,
it was fucking raining on this one thing.
I've learned that when you go to a football game and you're dealing with the
elements,
this is the more of a Douche bag you look like the warmer you're going to be.
All right.
I saw the rain and I said,
fuck this.
And we went right to Dick's sporting goods and I'm like,
I'm buying that fucking,
I'm gonna buy a raincoat with the matching raincoats slacks.
I don't give a fuck.
I bought a pair of a wool socks and I was good to go.
So I'm with [inaudible] and you know they only had like two raincoats left and
they were the exact same color.
This fucking grapes,
slush puppy purple.
So we both have matching extra large fucking jams.
We got the jacket and the pants like we're working at a fucking airport and what
green we're bringing in the fucking soul plane,
right?
That was a purple airplane,
That's what we look like.
So we show up to the game,
right?
Neither one of us is comfortable because neither one of us is a jets or a bills
fan.
So we're in enemy territory and it's fucking drizzling and out.
It's fucking cold.
So I proceed to put on this Barney the dinosaur outfit,
right?
And right off the bat,
Versie starts punkin outgoing man.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna wear that.
I'm just going to weigh the top.
I'm just going to weigh the top,
trying to act like it's not raining out that bad.
The reality is is he didn't want to go through the hazing that he would have to
if the two of us walked in with our purple on Purple fucking raincoats times
too,
we would have got a ton of shit and I was prepared to take it.
I had an,
I had a whole fucking silly walk I was going to be doing.
I don't give a fuck.
So he punked out.
So,
uh,
we ended up walking in and put my head's cold,
right?
All I have is a baseball cap on.
So I'm like,
fuck,
I gotta buy a hat.
Can I buy a bills?
Who gives a fuck?
They were in last place,
mangled by a bills hadn't.
Then I saw this,
this one with a Patriot logo on it.
I said,
fuck it.
I'll get that one.
So I put that one on.
I'm nice and warm.
We go to,
we'll call,
we pick up our tickets.
We go into that high school football stadium that they have out there that I
actually love.
It looks like an old school football stadium.
You know what I like about that football stadium that's about the size of a
football stadium that holds real fans.
You know what I mean?
All these,
these new ones that hold like 100,000 fucking pets,
all the bandwagon shitheads you know when you're all in for the real fucking
fans show up are all in three,
right?
So he walked into the Goddamn stadium with love in life,
I'm already laughing at Versie cause I know damn well what's going to happen?
He's going to walk out there.
There's going to be some shitty little plastic seat that's going to be covered
in fucking water and the only way he's going to be able to absorb it is through
his goddamn jeans and his fucking bbds.
And then he's going to be sitting there with a wrinkled up nuts sack that's
going to be getting hypothermia by second quarter.
Why do I know this?
Because I've been there.
So we get a couple of beers,
we get this fucking beef on a stick or whatever the fuck they call it.
We're good to go.
We go in there,
sit down,
he sits basically down in a fucking puddle.
He tried to stick a newspaper down,
which is a very absorbent and uh,
I don't know,
we sat there and I had hope for about eight seconds in that game and the jets
came down and just fucking Jew.
They just kicked the shit out of him.
Christ.
They kicked the shit out of 'em and uh,
it was just over.
So we'd,
so immediately,
our solution is just to start drinking the way we drank at the masters.
We're like,
fuck it,
let's,
let's get going here.
Right?
So we'll make a trip after trip and all of a sudden I gotta take a Piss,
right?
So I go and I'm standing in line and all of a sudden this does fucking six foot
five goofy looking jackass.
One of those guys who's like six foot five,
but you still think he can take him cause he's just covered in baby fat.
You know,
he's got a couple of whiskers on his chin and his cheeks are rosier than Saint
Nick,
right?
He's got this Jersey on and this big stupid,
I'm a buffalo bills fan with the horns on it and stuff,
you know,
he's the wacky guy,
so I'm not even thinking shit.
Right.
This is bill's jets.
I don't have a dog in this fight.
I'm not talking any shit.
I'm fine.
I forgot I was wearing my patriots hat and all of a sudden this big goofy
jackass starts going,
well,
what's what?
Yeah,
well you're a patriots fan.
He liked the rats.
We got a read over and the rats,
he likes to fucking rats and the shit right?
And I'm like,
Yay.
Yeah,
no,
whatever.
He starts giving me shit.
I started giving him shit back then the weirdest fucking thing happened.
I,
by the time I get in to the actual men's room,
I've talked,
I've given these people so much fucking shit that actually,
there's bills and jets fans at a bills and jets game.
They're playing each other.
They stopped giving each other shit and they teamed up together and started
giving me shit.
Right.
And then I just said,
I don't know what I was thinking.
I felt like I was on stage cause it was like a crowd.
I wasn't thinking like,
Hey,
you know what bill,
you really haven't had a fight outside of your family since maybe playing some
fucking street hockey in the sixth grade.
I didn't give a fuck.
I'm in a God damn bathroom waiting to take a piss in a goddamn trough by the
way.
And uh,
and then they just started giving a fuck fucking this one dude such going,
Tom Brady sucks.
Dig.
He Sucks Dick.
And he's like miming it like ridiculously well.
So I'm like,
hey you nobody do that.
Real wealth.
Because I learned it by watching Tom Brady.
Miko,
oh Yad,
you rent that porno,
you fucking fag gets a little uglier.
Gets a little uglier than this other dude.
What the fuck did I came up with the hell he was saying to me and I just said,
look,
I'm sorry you guys have never won a super bowl.
You know?
Then the jets fan pipes in.
I go,
do you realize the last time you guys won a super bowl,
Charlie Chaplin was still alive?
Do you understand that?
Do you know what cars look like the last time you won?
You fucking morons.
And then uh,
then this other guy go up until we've won three Superbowls.
I'm sorry.
Right.
And then the guy goes,
well you didn't play in the games.
I go,
neither did you.
Then he's just standing there with this dumb look on his face.
I go,
that's where I keep staring forward.
You got nothing forgetting that I don't know how to fight.
So all of a sudden it's my turn to pes.
I take my dick out,
I'm ready to Piss.
And one of these fucking pussies pushed me in the back hoping that I was pissing
at the time.
Fortunately I wasn't.
So I turn,
I put my dick away cause I'm a gentleman.
I said you,
I go,
is that how you guys do it out here?
Really?
I go,
which one you guys pushed me like I'm going to fuck.
I'm fucking Jackie Chan.
And for some reason none of them said anything.
I don't know if it was my purple on purple rain coat or the look of fire in my
eye,
but I'm a fucking 42 year old balding redhead talking shit in there and none of
them said anything.
So now it's kind of funny to me.
I felt like I was in like the world series of poker and I went all in and I,
and I didn't have a hand whatsoever,
so I don't know who the fuck pushed me,
but that's what I mean.
Come on.
Bitchy is move of the fucking week.
How do you do that?
How do you,
how do you push another man when he's got his Goddamn Dick out trying to piss it
to a fucking trough?
I mean,
how do you get lower than that?
Do you guys have any ideas?
How do you get lower than that?
So then after none of them said anything,
I go back and I started taking a piss.
And then that other dude who was miming somebody's sucking a dick unbelievably
well right next to me with one of those stupid hats that has the toggles on the
side and he's still trying to give me shit and I'm going to add,
go fuck yourself.
And then he just starts screaming over and over again.
Are you looking at my Dick?
How are you looking at my deck?
Like maniacally,
like five times.
I just sort of stared at him like why do you keep going this,
this gay angle?
Like why is there always a,
I dunno.
I think he was one of those guys.
He was kind of in the closet and then uh,
so he just goes to football games and he gets really drunk trying to just kill
the families.
I think he liked me.
It's what I'm saying.
So if he's listening to this,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm spoken for you fucking Pansy.
You fucking believe that first of all,
what's wrong with me?
I really replay it all of that in my head.
Cause once I got out of there I was like,
I really started thinking like,
what,
what did you think you were going to do in there?
They're not Clint Eastwood yet saying things.
Clint Eastwood would say,
what?
What the fuck is wrong with you dude?
Like I don't know if I've said this before in a podcast,
a public bathroom is the worst fucking place to ever get into a fight.
There is nothing soft.
This everything is porcelain pipes that concrete floor and then it has a mist of
piss and shit.
It's just a fucking,
it's the worst.
It's the worst place ever.
You know,
not to mention it usually starts evidently when one person as begun the pissing
process.
So,
uh,
you know,
older,
little bit wiser.
So then I'm standing in line to go get some more alcohol cause God knows that's
what you need after an incident like that.
And I was just kinda just sitting there thinking like,
all right,
now how should I have played that?
It w it should have ended when the dude with the water buffalo hat started
giving me shit.
What I should've done was roll with it.
I Shit you liked the Patriots.
I should have been like,
hey,
you know,
you guys scored 30 on his last week,
man.
You guys look great man.
I bet the jets,
I mean,
I bet against the jets.
I hope you guys should have just ended it with that.
Added it.
I've,
I sh I should,
uh,
I should have extended an olive branch.
That's what I should've done in the future.
That's what the fuck I'm going to do because,
uh,
that was a,
that was a potentially ugly situation,
but fortunately.
MMM,
okay.
I think the people who were doing it,
you know,
had jobs and no one wanted to get sued and no one was willing to take it to that
level.
Uh,
and when I say fortunately,
I mean for me and my face,
okay.
Oh,
do you know how bad that would have been to get stomped in that fucking purple
on purple rain coat laying there with my dirty fucking patriots' hat
and my team wasn't even playing.
Yeah,
I,
I would have lost the lawsuit.
They would have been like,
let me get this straight.
You're a patriots fan.
You were a patriots hat to a bill's jets game and you somehow managed to get the
shit kicked out of you.
What the fuck did you say?
You know,
that's one of the great things about being a guy is you actually have to take
responsibility for your,
for your actions.
See,
a woman would be like,
there's no excuse.
There's no reason.
I don't care what happened.
You know what?
He had a girl,
which is true.
You don't need a fucking girl,
but there's no learning in that.
There's no lesson.
You know?
Even my best friends would have been like,
yeah,
those guys are fucking assholes and the Bun,
you know,
that would've been an awkward pause.
I'm going to be like,
dude,
what the fuck he talking shit for by yourself at a game when your team isn't
even fucking playing.
What's wrong with you?
You 42 years old,
get your shit together and they would have been right.
So anyways,
fortunately the bills,
uh,
are smart enough to stop serving alcohol at halftime.
So when I went to go get more beer,
um,
there,
there wasn't any to be had.
So I walked back there and I'm laughing my ass off telling Versie the fucking
story.
And he informed me that fucking Sanchez threw a bomb to that fucking drunk
driver there.
And um,
and I was just like,
God,
Jesus,
here we go.
Here we go with the fucking patriots,
let up 30 points to this fucking team.
And the jets are raping him like this other patriots that bad.
I say we were at nine and 17,
now I'm thinking fucking seven and nine.
So,
uh,
whatever.
So that was rough.
And then ended up getting into it with some other jet Fan.
I'm just a Dick,
I'm a dick when I'm sober.
And then you add alcohol and that goes to the next level.
And then I don't,
when I go to a sporting event,
I become another person entirely.
I don't know what it is.
I just,
uh,
I don't know.
I love it.
I love being at the game.
I'm at the stadium,
I get excited and then I'm a dick and I say,
I say things that I shouldn't be saying.
And I just started giving this lady shit and she was bragging about the jets and
I just kept asking her over and over again,
what is it like to share a stadium?
You know,
why couldn't she just sit there and enjoy the fact that she was winning?
Why did I have to ruin it?
Why is my level of hatred for all New York teams to the,
to that level?
It's pathetic.
It's really pathetic.
But it is what it is.
So anyways,
most people would call it a day after that point,
but not me.
Not Jersey,
not us.
Fuck debt.
We're going to the sabers flyers game after this.
There's more beers to be drank.
So,
and we got to check out this fucking anchor bar to compare their wings to Duff's
right.
We're fucking doing buffalo up.
That's what you do.
You sit out in the fucking shit.
Uh,
whether you watch the bills,
get their ass kicked.
Yeomans get beat down with your dick out in the fucking bathroom.
And then you go get some wings and hit the Sabres game afterwards.
If there's something else to do out there.
I didn't see it.
Alright.
Niagara Falls,
one of my,
on my fucking honeymoon
anyways.
Who goes to Niagara Falls for their honeymoon?
Huh?
How far back into this staples warehouse are you working that,
that's where you go.
That's what I want to know.
So anyways,
uh,
fucking cruise back to the hotel,
get out of our fucking,
uh,
Barney the dinosaur fucking raincoats and uh,
I had to get directions.
We fucking flew down to the,
the Sabres game.
This is what kills me.
We go to,
we go to anchor bar.
First I was thinking of the game was at seven,
at eight.
Turns out it's at fucking six.
So we're pulling into anchor bar at a quarter to six.
Get ready to have some fucking wings was still,
we're just having a great time,
dude.
I can just put the windows down.
I could smell him.
This is going to be the shit,
right?
Just let it,
I literally gained like 20 pounds yesterday.
So right as we pull in,
the radio comes on and says,
you know,
the Sabres Marie dropped the puck in 15 minutes.
So we're like,
fuck.
And we start driving really fast,
not knowing where we were going to go because the plan was to get wings and
then,
you know,
with sauce on a Facebook,
oh,
whoa.
Shavers play.
That's that.
That was,
that was the game plan.
But now we have to fucking start driving and we ended up pulling over and uh,
these three black dudes walking across the street roll down the window,
Hey,
do you have any idea where the sabers,
hi,
look at me breaking down stereotypes.
And it turns out,
uh,
the dude where after actually African,
oh,
we go where,
you know,
how do we get to the HSBC SSC fucking arena?
And he's like,
oh,
did is very far.
You hit the ball.
I carry,
I can't do an African accent,
but I could just tell the way he was rolling his eyes that it was really far,
but I was thinking,
wait a minute,
this guy's walking.
Does he mean by bus?
Who the fuck knows?
Whatever.
Long story short,
we ended up getting up there,
so we just think we're going to walk up.
It's a preseason game,
but just going to buy tickets at the booth.
No can do.
I think I bought a bad pack of batteries.
They said fucking Duracell on him.
I think they were bootleg.
These God damn things that are really good for a half a fucking hour.
All right,
let's pick up the pace with the damn story again.
So we walk up there,
it's a,
it's a preseason game and we'd go up to buy tickets and they're sold out.
Unbelievable for the Sabres flyers that were like,
fuck,
they're going to drop the puck in five minutes.
We go,
we got to go scalps some tickets and I didn't see anybody selling near the
arena.
And I came walking out and I see this nerdy looking white dude with a sweater
walking up and I just yelled,
who's got tickets?
And he's goes,
I got two right here,
I got two right here.
And then we'll fucking bottom off 60 bucks a whack.
Sat right on the club level.
They've got everything from Sushi to,
I don't think I have Sushi,
but he had like ice cream,
which is really fucking ridiculous at a hockey game.
Maybe you get an ice cream sandwich,
but they had like,
it looked like a,
what's that Italian rest?
Uh,
not restaurant.
They had Italian ice cream.
That's the gelato.
They get like that level ice cream.
You know,
are you really going to come back with that on a cone licking a cone?
As you watch two people beat the shit out of each other.
Um,
so anyways,
so then we get,
it's just,
first of all the sabers arena is the shit.
All right.
For the exact opposite.
Read a reason that I love the buffalo.
I love the Buffalo Bills Stadium because it reminds me,
it's what,
it's,
what football stadiums look like when I was a kid.
And I'm not insulting you guys out there.
I think it's the shit.
I like it.
I hate those brand new fucking stadiums that are the size of a god Damn
Mountain.
I hate him.
I can't stand them.
They're too fucking expensive.
They rape you in the ass for four tickets because they got to pay for the Fat
Fox who sit in the luxury boxes,
who don't even give a shit about the damn team and they want to sit inside and
watch a game.
Fuck all those places.
So,
but the Sabres,
as far as a new arena,
man that's right up there with,
uh,
as far as the new arenas goes,
the best one I've seen.
I like the Minnesota wild.
The Phoenix coyotes had a really nice one.
And the worst one I've been to was the Boston Bruins.
We have the worst brand new fucking arena you are ever going to go to.
It's like a bomb shelter.
They went out,
they went down to the fucking Grossman's hardware and they bought up all the
cinder blocks in the state.
That's what they did.
And then they just glued them together and painted them yellow and fucking
black.
There you go.
That's what we will put the Bruins and the 17 time world champion Boston Celtics
Day you go give you some yellow plastic seats.
Have fun everybody
but the sabers arena,
man,
I was,
it was beautiful.
Scoreboard was to shit.
And they had the uh,
the sabers head hang and that was fucking awesome.
And then with the game was nine to two Sabres kicked the shit out of him.
And uh,
you know,
I was making fun of those people who listened to the radio when they a watch a
game,
like what?
You can't see what the fuck's going on?
Well,
evidently I couldn't because I saw what I thought was uh,
uh,
Daniel Carsello getting beaten down to the ice.
I saw this saber and this flyer go at it and they appeared to both drop the
gloves and the Saber guy went wet dash where dash twice,
straighten this guy's face.
And by the second one the guy was falling backwards to the ice and he did,
you know that final UFC,
you're not knocked out enough.
I'm going to punch you as you're on the ground overhand,
right where damage to his fucking face.
And I was like,
wow.
Wow.
Who was that?
Who did that?
And who was that?
Who got fucked up?
And then five minutes later cars Scilla was over by the penalty box and he got a
game misconduct.
I go,
did he do that to Carsello and was he embarrassed?
So he came out and he tried to do a handsome brother thing and fight him.
The second the dude came out and uh,
it turned out it wasn't him,
it was somebody else.
And I heard he didn't even drop the gloves,
which is,
who explained why,
what does,
what does happen?
How do you do that?
How do you not drop the gloves when someone else drops the gloves?
Even if you don't want to fight,
can't you just fucking drop the gloves to hang on and turn the other way and
give up the back of your head?
How I would have fought in that bathroom.
Oh,
the noise.
Can you imagine the noise of five people trampling me?
The echoing the perfect acoustics of a fucking God damn men's room.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
and then we ended the night,
the end of the night we,
uh,
we saw a great God damn game,
saw that six 48 psychopath that I want to see Chara fight on defense.
And then we went,
uh,
we left and went down to anchor bar and we show up and get this for the third
time in the history of that place.
They ran out of wings.
They ran out of winks.
Like you fucking kidding me.
Went down there to watch the giants game first.
He's a big giants fan,
right?
So we go,
fuck it.
We'll stay here anyways.
And uh,
I dunno,
ask Paul about the edge.
I don't want to trash the place cause I know which legendary,
but go on Paul's Facebook page and ask him how he enjoyed the mixed drinks there
because a,
he had a little issue,
he had a little bit of an issue there.
You know what I mean?
You know the deal.
Let me get,
let me get absolute uh,
on the rocks and Eh,
absolutely.
You know,
and then you just see them pouring it out of a fucking jelly jar and you're
like,
yeah.
What,
what kind of absolute is that?
Eh,
Yah,
absolutely.
Uh,
my friends vodka that he makes down the street,
you fucking prick.
So we actually didn't have a good time and anchor bar.
We showed up and uh,
they were out of wings and then they tried to pass off as some shit.
Vodka is the real thing.
Is that how they do it at the anchor bar?
I'm still going to go back there and try their wings.
I gotta I gotta check it out.
I mean,
I liked everything inside.
You go inside there and they had like fucking,
it was like a motorcycle museum,
like real motorcycles above it.
They had licensed plates everywhere from like Hawaii to like the northwest
territories.
They like license plate shaped like a bear in there.
That's how far north these fucking ice road truckers come to calm down and get
them sales,
some fucking buffalo wings.
So we did it up.
We did Buffalo,
you know,
actually if I got into a fight and loss but didn't really get hurt,
that really would have made,
that would have been great.
A little bit of blood in my purple fucking rain coat.
The fuck is wrong with me.
But let's get to the questions this week everybody.
This is actually a really a considering that that happened and um,
all right,
let me,
I just had somebody sent me a great
podcast question about that under the new topic,
sports cuts.
Um,
and by the way,
I'm going to get out of the sports talk after a while cause like remember when I
went real hardcore conspiracy theory and talked about banks every week and then
that got boring.
Well,
the sports thing is only going to be interesting for so fucking long,
but uh,
we are,
we're really in the throes of it right now.
I know for a lot of you,
this is like during the soprano's when Tony was in that fucking a out of body
state where he walked around,
didn't talk like Tony Soprano.
Remember that Shit.
Do Ya?
Okay.
Um,
let me adjust the levels here.
Hope these aren't too loud.
Okay,
so here it goes.
Sports cons,
uh,
Bill.
Um,
all right.
Anyway,
uh,
all of your jets hating made me want to email you a,
I went to the jets pats game for week two.
I'm a patriots fan by the way,
and I'd love to hear you,
uh,
your take on fans who attend football games.
It's fucking incredible.
I went with my girlfriend who was wearing a Brady Jersey.
Now know that this isn't a way game.
Everybody,
okay.
They went to New Jersey to watch the New York jets play in giants stadium.
It's judge joy,
which fucking middle is shut up.
Um,
we pull into the parking lot and every,
and people were literally moving their chairs into the open parking open parking
space,
not letting me park saying patriots aren't allowed here.
And He,
the guy writes,
ha ha ha,
I get it now.
Can you please move?
No one would fucking move.
It's amazing.
It's like,
okay,
I fucking get it.
You hate the patch now.
Get the fuck out of my way and let me park.
So they finally move and we get out and start walking towards the stadium.
He goes,
these people start following us,
calling us every name you can think of.
Um,
and he's like,
like,
really?
Do you have a f?
F what?
Do you have a fucking family or anything else in your life?
You take this game,
this seriously?
I would've said something,
but there were like nine guys.
Well,
Hey,
welcome to my world.
Welcome to mind.
Well,
he just thank,
thank God you weren't taking a piss at that time.
Uh,
but they were like nine guys and like six girls calling me a patriots loving
faggot.
Then he writes faggot.
Really?
So we keep walking and pass.
Some normal people who heckle in the right way.
You're going down,
Brady sucks.
I get that.
Ha Ha.
It's fine.
Um,
breast come back by the way is just to keep walking through the parking lot,
responding with 1969.
They hate that,
but I only pull that card in response.
Okay.
So now we're going up the escalator.
Some guys going the other way on the escalator and starts screaming.
You're almost as ugly as that fucking Brady Jersey you have on.
Oh,
they're saying that to your girlfriend.
Wow.
Go Back to Boston.
You faggot a what the fuck?
Uh,
then,
uh,
at our seats there was a fucking juiced up roid head screaming his fucking face
off,
turning red,
punching the shit out of the seats,
screaming the entire game.
There was a fucking dad and his 12 year old daughter in front of us.
Anyway,
I just love to hear your take on these fucking lunatics.
Like,
I get it.
You love football,
but really,
is there nothing else in your life that you take,
uh,
this seriously?
Um,
all right.
well,
you're talking to a guy who's been on boats.
I've never gone,
I've never called someone a faggot.
I never do that.
There's more of us than you.
So much trying to intimidate you.
Think I'm more the,
uh,
loan wise ass talking shit to someone who can beat the shit out of me.
But this is what you got to understand.
All right?
Just to avoid these situations as sports fans,
um,
this is,
this is what I've found.
You can,
all right,
first of all,
if you're going to go into another person's stadium,
okay.
And not only where,
and not the other team's Jersey,
but the Jersey of a team that is literally kicked the shit out of the other
team.
I mean,
the Patriots since 2001 have basically kicked the shit out of the jets twice a
year.
Every fucking year for almost 10 years or the very least,
we've won like 80% of the fucking games.
Um,
so that jersey,
it's like,
you know,
you got to understand that's,
yeah.
You're,
you're bringing up a lot of bad memories.
Um,
and I,
yeah,
those people who actually don't let you park there.
Yeah.
They are taking it too far,
that there's a little bit on both sides,
you know what I mean?
It's like you kind of,
you know,
slice in your leg and then jumping in a shark infested water and then getting
upset that you get in your fucking leg bid off.
I mean,
I think it's bullshit.
I don't know,
but I do get it.
Like people should get shit.
Okay.
That roided out guys.
Who's,
who's punching the back of the seats like that?
I mean,
that's,
that's kind of par for the course.
I hate to say it,
it is par for the course.
Like the eagles fans really get,
or Philly fans get way too much credit for psychos.
They kind of act,
it's kind of like racism,
how they act like it's only white people in the south,
you know,
like that's where it is.
And it's kind of like Philly gets all the shit or credit depending if you're
proud of it.
And not that like only moron asshole fans are in Philly.
I mean,
I've been to games in Philly.
The word,
one of the worst experiences I had was,
uh,
going to a San Diego chargers game once again with my Patriot fucking hat on
like an asshole.
You'd think I'd learned from that.
Um,
yeah,
my take on that is,
you know,
there should be this fun talking shit and then there's the talking shit where
it's not fun.
Like someone pushes you way trying to take a piss or they start,
you know,
saying your girlfriend's ugly or whatever the fuck they were trying to say
there.
Um,
but you know,
if you wear the Jersey Elio team,
you walk in,
you got to expect that someone's going to call you a pussy or probably throw the
last bite of their hot dog at you.
What's going to happen?
People are drinking and uh,
you know,
a lot of people don't like their lives.
They don't like who they're married to.
Maybe they don't like their job.
Um,
or maybe they're just a dick,
who knows.
But you got to understand that basically,
you know,
you wore the Jersey of a team that's won three super bowls into the stadium.
Have a team that,
like I said,
Charlie Chaplin was alive the last time that jet's wanted.
Okay.
Harry Truman was alive.
Dwight d Eisenhower was alive the last time that jet's wanted.
All right.
And I'm not trying to give the judge Shit,
I'm just,
I'm just trying to show compassion here.
Brett Farve wasn't even alive the last time that jets it.
Okay.
So you,
you gotta,
you gotta be a little more compassionate to the jets fan.
I mean,
like the Dallas cowboys were considered bridesmaids could always get to the big
dance,
but could never win it.
The last time the jets,
when the Superbowl,
you know,
Richard Nixon was president.
Spiro Agnew was vice president.
Costs of a new home was $27,500.
That was the average price.
Average cost of a new car was $3,270 the last time that Jay,
I'm not giving the judge Shit here by bringing out these staggering facts.
I'm just trying to say,
you know,
you gotta,
you gotta show a little compassion.
You have to understand that these poor bastards,
the last time they want it,
the population of this country was only at 202 million.
Do you understand that
they have one in a long fucking time,
price of gas was 35 fucking sense.
Do you really think that you're gonna walk in with the Jersey of a guy who's
created them so much fucking misery,
who has a haircut that they can't stand?
Who's banging the hottest fucking broad in the planet right now?
You don't live in the life that they want to live,
but can't,
you know,
as they strain in the upper deck to try to figure out what the fuck is going on.
Yes.
You're going to get called a faggot.
Do I think it's right?
No,
I,
I wish there was friendlier ball busting.
I really wish that more people knew how to break balls and including myself.
More people knew when to shut the fuck up like me.
You know,
like I should have,
I should have tapped out buddy and I didn't.
So,
uh,
anybody have any a bad sporty.
What's your worst experience as a fan?
Like I could tell you,
like back in the day,
I would wear like a red sox hat to a Yankees game in Yankee stadium before 2004,
I would do it because,
you know,
we had,
what did we do to them except blow leads and lose.
But once we fucking hung the biggest choke and professional sports history
around the God damn next,
then it became a different thing.
And then we wanted it again.
And then all of a sudden I noticed it started getting hostile.
I was like,
all right,
this isn't cool anymore.
This isn't being taken is that this isn't a funny thing anymore.
This I'm not the fucking,
uh,
the fucking happy go lucky kid who was just hoping to see it once.
I've seen it twice since the last time they want it.
And I,
it noticeably got ugly the same way the Patriot's stadium went from a,
an absolute fucking zoo to being this,
this sort of classier place to go see a Goddamn game when we were winning.
And that was the thing.
Anybody can be classy when they're winning,
but you know,
you see who the fans really are when you're fucking losing.
Yeah.
Like when the Patriots,
I mean,
red sox finally beat the Yankees and that they didn't like when a rod slap the
ball down.
They didn't like that.
They didn't get that call.
Like they had been so many other fucking years.
That goddamn fans pulling routine fly balls into the fucking stands for home
runs.
Reggie Jackson leaning into the ball.
They always get those calls and all of a sudden they didn't get and they threw
fucking temper tantrum started littering the field.
Right.
The classy Manhattan nights that they are.
So,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Um,
yes.
Basically all sports fans behavior needs to be a needs to improve.
And uh,
it starts with me just like that Michael Jackson Song.
Huh?
Starting with the man in the mirror.
Um,
no one did.
They push me purple on purple rain coat.
I wasn't even fucking thick and I would've pushed me too.
All right.
Question of the week.
Uh,
somebody wrote bill,
why do you hate stoners?
Oh yeah.
Cause last week I was making fun of my stone of friend.
Uh,
I don't hate stoners.
I was,
I'm,
I don't like stoners who call me up and trash my life because they don't like
their own.
All right.
Stop making it about yourself.
All right,
Eh,
ah,
this person actually wrote and thought that I smoked weed,
which is a,
that's one of the things that is a known annoying about stoners is after they
smoke long enough,
they think that the only way to have creative thought is to be sucking the Dick
of that plant.
Okay.
Well,
I just lost my stone pub.
I just don't,
uh,
um,
I don't,
you know what it is.
I don't like the fucking,
I don't like putting smoke into my lungs.
I just,
you know,
there's two things.
You don't want your lungs,
okay.
You don't want smoke and you don't want water.
So I wouldn't slowly inhale a glass of water.
You know,
and slowly drown myself over 60 years.
I wouldn't do that either.
But,
uh,
I have to admit,
I,
I've tried weed a couple of times.
I didn't try it until I was like 37 to how hilarious is that?
And then I finally tried it and it was exactly what I was afraid of was I
fucking loved it.
But,
uh,
I just can't,
I just can't get that,
that image of that person is smoking through the hole in their throat.
I just,
yeah.
I don't want lung cancer,
so I don't fuck with it.
But,
uh,
it's a lot harder to see your liver shriveling up as you booze.
MMM.
Anyways.
Hey Bill,
have you seen the,
uh,
the infomercial for the I renew bracelet?
I'm sure you have.
It's this magic bracelet that makes you have better balance,
strength,
endurance,
and sleep better.
Hell,
you might even be wearing one right now to bring up,
to bring the funny out in you.
Uh,
it's a little piece of rubber with the shiny piece of metal on it probably cost
$2 to make a hundred of them.
Um,
it channels your body's energy or some shit.
Maybe it works.
I don't know.
You know what's crazy?
People are buying these things for $20 a pop.
Someone is getting rich off this gimmick.
God bless them for finding an angle to make some dough.
Uh,
I think it's in the same category as the $50 gold coins for 10 bucks.
Yeah,
it's exactly at,
I think whoever came up with that as a genius and those really bad actors where
they,
they act like they can't stand upright.
Yet somehow they were able to make it to the mall to go on film with those
stupid braces.
And the second they put the bracelet on,
oh my God.
It's amazing.
Like I can't believe it.
Um,
the APP,
Bryce,
which are a great way to go.
You know what you do make a bracelet that actually says a,
it'll make your dick bigger or give you a flat tummy for the ladies.
You know,
something like that.
I Dunno,
I'm getting sleepy again.
I've told you some good stories here,
haven't I?
You know,
the last time that jet's won the Superbowl,
Jim Brown was the all time rusher leading rusher.
And behind him was Joe Perry,
not from Aero Smith.
Joe Perry from 1948 or so.
I don't really know all the fuck he played for the top three with Jim Brown,
Joe Perry and Jim Taylor.
Okay.
The guy from fucking Aerosmith was second behind Jim Brown in rushing.
That's how long it's been since the jets have one.
It's so,
yeah,
you can't wear a Tom Brady Jersey d down there by the way.
Thank God my patriots fucking one tonight.
Jesus Christ.
And I'll tell you as much as the score was,
uh,
you know,
lopsided,
there is a lot of water.
There's a lot of water leaking into that ship.
Jesus Christ,
I don't know what the fuck is with our defense,
but so much of the game we look like we're in a prevent,
it's fucking ridiculous.
So my big prediction this week,
now,
my big prediction,
my big question this week is if Ben Roethlisberger comes back,
doesn't miss a goddamn step and just plays the way that guy can play.
And that defense plays the way it's been playing.
Uh,
I put them a top,
the AAFC I would say that they had,
they are the team to beat the fact that they went three and one with a third
string fucking quarterback and basically all,
I mean we're,
we're what they lost in like the last play of the game.
They know they would,
they were that close to going for no,
that's how good their fucking defenses.
And then not only that,
that third string quarterback got all that experience.
I'll tell you if big Ben comes in,
right and just kicks ass and then they just stick them in an armored car and
they drive him past all those Hooters and just get them home.
I think the Steelers might be going for number seven.
How fucking Badass would that be?
That would be that.
That would be something.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
I remember a couple of years ago we were one Superbowl behind them.
Like here we go,
Steelers and next we're going to catch them.
And then what happened?
Nothing.
Then they want to more so we're fucking in the dust again.
All right,
asshole friends.
I asked you guys for some stories about asshole friends.
Here's one for you.
Uh,
just wanting to,
so,
uh,
the,
the right off the bat.
Okay,
where do I start this?
Fuck you guys.
I'm tired when I just start at the beginning.
He just wanted to say and know exactly what it's like to have a buddy always
seems to have shit in his diaper and just has that puppy dog look in his eye
that says,
hey bro,
can you deal with my shit before I get a rash?
Uh,
last night I was at a local bar just relaxing and enjoying a couple of beers
with the girl I'd been talking to and a buddy I hadn't seen in about a year.
Moseys on over.
I'm excited.
You know,
he's an old high school buddy and I'm expecting to have a good couple of good
last with this guy right off the bat.
I ask him how he's doing.
Uh,
just expecting them to say,
you know,
say something like,
good,
how about you?
Like any normal icebreaking human being,
right?
But he says,
I say,
how you doing?
Uh,
he just size
and looks at his beer and then do his feet.
And I'm just like,
God damn it.
Here we go.
He goes on about,
I was,
mommy kicked him out of the House that he's got something wrong with his neck,
that a heat pad won't get out,
something about a Dui.
Then he has the nerve to complain how he got turned down for government
assistant checks.
It's like,
if,
have you ever heard of AIDS in Africa,
motherfucker of Jesus.
You went all the way to the end with that one.
Uh,
needless to say,
I'm getting annoyed at this point,
and I say,
well shit man.
You know,
we all got to grow up.
What a great fucking line.
Then I offered to talk to my boss to try and get this guy a job so he can get
back on his feet.
He then looks offended,
pissed off that he didn't rub his belly wipe is bubbling lips and tell him
everything was going to be just fine and throw a couple of quarters into his
Little Tin Cup.
Exactly,
exactly.
How old are you fucking move on and get a God damn job,
you bum.
Um,
so anyways,
the guy announces when he,
after the kid said,
uh,
you know,
we all got to grow up sometime he,
and he announces I wasn't born to be a slave dude.
Fuck that noise.
And I'm just thinking,
yeah,
maybe you shouldn't have been born at all.
As I turned back to my lady,
I know that's a harsh thought,
but when you're born with the fully functioning brain in a nice area,
with a good educational system,
with every opportunity in the world to not suck,
and you still apply for government assistance,
it's like,
do as tacs rape victims of favor and do a triple Lindy Rodney Dangerfield styled
down a flight of fucking unforgiving.
All right.
Uh,
yeah,
I'd have to go with you on that one.
Um,
yeah,
those guys are,
they're the fucking worst.
I love that.
You said that to him too.
Well,
you know,
we all got to grow up sometime.
I wasn't put on this year to be a slave marriage.
What are you a fucking king?
You just going to sit around and have other people bring wealth to.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I got no comeback for him.
I'm fucking exhausted.
I'm going to wrap this up then I shut it off again.
No,
I did not know.
All right.
Let's wrap it up with a little overrated,
underrated and some youtube videos for the week.
Um,
overrated.
Uh,
popular rap and hip hop music since 1994.
Um,
if a six month old song is considered dated and dead,
then it wasn't good to begin with.
No one listens to Zhao rule or Nelly or 50 cent anymore.
Just like no one will listen to Kanye West or little Wayne in five years.
If music we're a food than modern mainstream rap would be Mcdonald's.
It's on every corner.
Easy to put together and it gives grownups horrible diarrhea.
All right.
I don't know much about hip hop,
but you don't think little Wayne
50 cent?
No.
Uh,
since 1994.
What about Biggie?
Didn't like any of this shit.
There's a couple of guys I know wasn't Nas illmatic wasn't that around then?
I don't know about that album,
but everybody says that album's unbelievable.
I know what you're saying though.
All these auto tune fucking songs out there.
I get it.
All right.
Underrated.
Not going out every weekend and spending $100 at a bar or a club.
Yeah,
I'm 21 and I'm supposed to get out there and have fun,
meet New People and Shit.
But like you said,
it's hard to meet girls when it sounds like you've got a bass drum chilling in
your ear.
Just nod.
Just not in a way it's some broad,
you know,
you won't sleep,
won't sleep.
What?
Just nodding away at some broad,
you know,
you won't sleep with and you're just hoping to,
God she didn't just ask you a question that requires an answer.
Call me lame.
But I'd rather hang out on a porch on a nice night with some good friends,
sweet girls,
just fucking drinking a good beer.
You write a country song here,
hanging out on the front porch.
We some good friends in sweet girls drink.
It's an fucking good bear with the game on me and a good conversation and rock
and roll in a CD player.
I'm not writing these lyrics.
Maybe you won't wake up with a hole in your pocket.
Bleed nears.
Let's do it for America.
Keep it up,
motherfucker.
Yeah.
All right.
Youtube videos.
Yeah,
I hear what you're saying dude.
Yeah.
Chill at home.
Fucking trying to bang the girl next door.
There you go.
Save you money.
And with that I am with that.
I got a a underrated,
uh,
not having a bunch of dumb dumb whores with their tits and ass is hanging out,
run out on a football field during halftime.
I want the old fucking school bands to come back out again.
Did you see that?
A horse shit tonight.
You know Kelly Rowland up in the stands said,
oh,
it was the girl from Destiny's child.
We have ASVAB is that
gives a fuck.
Who gives up?
Then she's up in the stand,
like the desperately trying to make music without a band.
Interesting.
I'm sick of it.
I want musicians to come back,
you know,
and I want him to play in musical fucking,
uh,
atmospheres.
I don't want to see you a fucking football game.
Get a goddamn hundred men marching band to come out there.
Right?
Just play the old school songs.
But I am ADAP bap,
bap Bam and Amsterdam.
Bam,
Bam and eminent.
Yeah,
but that's shit.
You fucking coming out there with you God damn shit.
Talking about breast cancer.
I understand.
I know.
It's a problem.
You didn't write your fucking song for breast cancer.
You try to use breast cancer now to,
to,
to sell some more fucking cds.
Huh?
Because that other one with the awful voice is selling more than you.
Is that what you're doing?
How is that less offensive than Janet Jackson's titty coming out as fucking
beyond me.
Tell you that right now?
You know all those fucking horse walking around with their fucking asses and
titties hanging out.
You know,
why don't you fucking get a God damn job.
You dumb whores,
Jesus.
Fuck.
What would you be doing if he didn't have half your goods hanging out of your
fucking shorts?
You know?
Do you have any fucking talent whatsoever?
You could do a split.
Great,
fantastic.
Does that mean you got to put on some cowboy boots and get stuck to the goddamn
astro turf in front of 80,000 fucking people on Monday night football?
I don't think it does.
I don't think it means that at all.
I think that's,
that's a sign that you suck as a musician.
If you sing at halftime at a football game,
that pretty much means either you suck,
your music sucks,
or you've completely sold out as a god damned musician.
All right,
and that goes to those fucking concert.
Play the Superbowl too.
I don't give a shit fucking Bruce Springsteen screaming about dip and then
sliding around on his fucking knees like he's not 60 Jesus Christ.
He got some good plastic surgery,
right?
That guy was like 35455550640 one he's 41 again,
I don't know how the fuck he did it.
He got his face.
He yanked back and it actually looks good.
You know why?
Cause they practiced on all those real housewives of fucking New Jersey in
Orange County and all that shit.
That's what they did.
They practiced on their faces and they went,
oh,
let's not do that again.
All right,
let's scratch that technique of the list.
Let's,
let's try this.
Oh,
that's a little bit better.
She only looks like half a lizard.
That's what you got to do.
Like I said,
it's like fucking hair plugs,
hair plugs in the goddamn nineties looked horrific.
And now I've got to tell you,
these guys swimming around in the pools,
you know,
aside from the psychotic look in their eye,
like,
do I look okay?
Other than that they're their hairline.
I mean,
I can't tell.
All right.
Youtube videos for the week.
I was talking about those free videos,
free climbers or jumpers or whatever the fuck it was.
Free runners.
I wanted to see a chase scene and somebody said a,
here's a video district,
be 13 chasing.
Um,
I have,
these are actually,
I have more,
these are just weird videos this week.
Okay.
That's actually a cool one.
Here's a weird one,
a proper possum,
pedicure,
search that,
um,
and then this is one,
I swear to God,
I didn't even think it was real,
but look up,
look up sweet home Alabama and there's some lady singing it.
Just scroll down past all the Leonard Skinner and just look for the fat woman
with one tooth.
And uh,
for some reason I don't think that she realized that it got a million and a half
hits.
Um,
and here's another one.
Look up fake rapture prank.
This is all one word,
fake rapture.
Our AP,
t,U r e prank,
all one word.
It's basically,
do you guys know what the rapture is?
Oji Do you know what that is?
That's basically when Jesus,
right before Jesus comes back.
Now,
correct me if I'm wrong,
people in Florida,
um,
I guess right before he comes back,
like people who are going to come to go to heaven,
like they're going to be sitting across from you,
like fucking absent.
Mindedly like picking their nose,
thinking about,
you know,
what they're going to do that evening,
and then all of a sudden they're just not going to be there,
but their clothes will be there because evidently you have to be naked to go to
heaven,
right?
So your clothes are going to be there just left behind.
And then everybody who's not going to happen gets left behind.
And then,
uh,
the whole world turns into like the,
that island on survivor where I think there's only one person's gonna win.
I don't know what you can try to do to redeem yourself,
but basically Jesus is coming back and this time he's not asking any questions.
There'll be no miracles,
no fucking seven o'clock show where he does the fish trick with the basket.
No walking on water,
none of horseshit.
He's coming back like fucking Paul Kersey.
Right?
Is that the name was that fucker Charles Bronson's name and the death wish
movies.
He's coming back to fucking kick the shit out of all the centers,
make it was coming back to slap me around a little bit and then throw me into
the fiery pits of hell.
So,
uh,
they found this Jesus Freak girl and these Jesus Freak people thought it would
be funny to fake the rapture and make this fucking Jesus freak chick think that
she got left behind.
And,
uh,
the fact that this girl is an adult and it gets this freaked out is really the
sad state of,
uh,
of what organized religion does to somebody that somebody this old could,
could get freaked out by something like this is fucking beyond me.
And,
um,
it's tragic.
I would speak to that.
Somebody,
I can't find where it was.
Somebody wanted me to ask me about that story where those college kids,
uh,
these college kids taped this other kid either having sex or fooling around this
other college kid and it turned out he was with another dude.
So then the kid was so humiliated because I guess he wasn't out that he went to
the George Washington bridge and killed himself.
And,
uh,
I guess somebody wanted me to comment on that.
That's obviously a,
yeah,
that's one of those fucking things where it's like,
even though they're adults,
they're still kids.
And,
uh,
I don't think that they,
I don't think that people understand even at that age.
I just don't think that a lot of people understand the ramifications of what
they're doing sometimes.
Like how,
first of all,
how fucked up it is to just film somebody the invasion of privacy that that is.
And then when you discovered this about this person,
just the level of humiliation that I don't know why you would do that to
somebody.
Uh,
but
so for an unprecedented third time,
the fucking batteries die.
I got a bootleg bag,
a fucking thing,
a Duracell's here.
So let me wrap it up here.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
as a,
as a fucking free thinking adult,
I would never,
I would never do something like that to somebody,
but that age,
you know what?
I had the courage to be like,
guys,
this is fucking wrong.
Don't do that.
Like,
I don't think I would have to be on,
I hate to say that about myself,
but I wasn't a strong individual back then as I think a lot of people aren't at
that age,
which is tragically how something like that unfolds.
But what's going to be fucked up as the amount of people getting on their high
horse,
forgetting what you like at that age and how so much of it is trying to keep the
uh,
humiliation off of you.
It's a lot of humiliation and your teen years actually it's your childhood right
up through those years.
So you finally just accept who the fuck you are,
which is what that kid never got to a chance to do,
which is really sad thing and then freak the fuck out.
And it made a really bad decision.
So,
yeah,
it's a fucking tragic story obviously,
but,
well,
I don't like how people,
once they are an adult and a comfortable in their own fucking skin and who they
are,
we'll then turn around and they're going to start yelling at these fucking kids
like,
uh,
like they,
they would have been,
you know,
strong enough to go against the,
uh,
the mob,
you know,
it's fucked up.
All right.
You're dealing with kids who are technically adults,
but mentally they don't understand,
you know,
what are they thinking?
Oh,
this is going to be funny,
you know,
and then,
uh,
we'll have the most hits on our fucking youtube page and then maybe everyone
will come to our house party and then we'll get laid,
right?
I mean,
do they really think anywhere beyond that?
You don't really think that,
okay,
this is a fucking huge secret.
We just unraveled on this kid.
His kid has family.
This kid has friends.
Let's get as a life.
You don't think that Shit,
you just,
I dunno.
It's that residual.
A
fucking playground.
Shit.
So I don't know,
man.
I know it's a fucking off.
What the fuck did I bring?
That story up in the end was already a fucking brutal enough week.
Um,
I don't know why the fuck did I go that route?
All right,
let's,
let's fucking get off that subject.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast this week.
My Yard DVD,
my DVD comes out,
um,
comes out tomorrow,
Tuesday the fifth in stores,
whatever stores still sell it and it makes a great stocking stuffer as I said,
for someone that you have to buy a gift for but don't particularly like,
or if somebody you do like,
and I gotta tell you this is really totally different than the special that you
saw on TV if you've already seen it.
They really took out two huge bits and then I had other bits that,
uh,
we just have on there as extras and a,
I would really appreciate it if you'd be,
if you check it out,
if you buy it,
that would be a,
that would be awesome.
And uh,
and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Once again,
thanks to everybody who came out to see me at the egg and Albany and everybody
who came out to see me out in Buffalo.
And uh,
that is it.
Everybody have a good week and a,
yeah,
don't be fucking videotape and people trying to humiliate a,
all right.
And if you were the jealousy where we got this week and don't fucking wear the
Jersey or the hat of a team that kicks the shit out of another team and going to
their Goddamn stadium and expect that you're going to be treated even remotely
human.
Okay.
All right,
ed.
Uh,
and that's it.
That's fucking it.
How'd you like Dad fucking jets fans?
Will fucking patriots are slowly coming back together.
I still don't,
I don't,
I still don't believe yet.
I still don't fucking believe yet.
It's still think that Jetson going on when the God damn division,
as much as,
I hate to say it,
but,
uh,
I still,
I think of Ben comes back there.
My Hope,
because I think the colts are reeling.
I'm hope this is how much I fucking hate the jets.
I'm actually going to root for the fucking stealers,
those currency,
while he's talking about bill Bellacheck filming the other team and completely
ignore that the super Steelers of the 70s were fucking roided out of their
minds,
out of their fucking minds.
You don't believe me?
Go ask Fran Tarkington.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].